Film Courage: Trae you said you’ve been
here 15 years now from Chicago?
Trae Ireland: Yes.
Film Courage: If there had been a handbook
that someone was going to deliver to you and
say “This is for you” and you will learn
all of this, but it’s going to take 15 years,
what do you wish had been in this handbook?
Trae Ireland: Money.
[Laughs]
Film Courage: Exactly.
Okay.
Trae Ireland: No…because you have to survive.
Los Angeles is so expensive.
If you are a struggling actor or anybody who
comes out here, the cost of living is so high
you can’t…it’s hard for you to get a
regular job because you have to pursue this.
You have to do auditions and meetings and
all this, so you’ll get fired or you’ll
get laid off from your job.
So you have to have money to be able to have
that cushion to be able to pursue this…but
ask the question again so I can give you another
answer?
Film Courage: Sure.
But that’s good.
I like that book actually.
I wish someone had handed me that.
But what else in that book could tell you
different things [such as] don’t waste your
time with this, spend more time on that which
you wish someone had given to you that you’ve
learned now where.
And in turn, you could then hand this same
book to someone?
Trae Ireland: Here is the irony of that because
you just never know.
Because there is a lot of that when I first
got here I would try a lot of these showcases
or whatever, don’t go to those.
They are a rip-off because a lot of these
casting directors at these showcases they
are trying to make their own money and pay
their own bills.
And they are not really invested to find somebody
but if they do “Oh!
I just found this guy.”
So it’s so unorthodox.
There is not a set blueprint so to have that
book…it’s just experiences.
It should be like a book of just experiences
and you just learn.
That’s why I watch all those backstories
on everybody.
The most important thing is just to commit
to whatever it’s going to be that you are
going to do.
And that is to do your research to whatever
the character’s going to be, whatever you
choose.
I don’t care if you want to work at The
Home Depot.
If you want to be the head cashier you have
to commit to whatever it is.
Put the hours in, the work.
So that book is mainly just to stay focused
on what you want to do and just enjoy the
experience, even if the bad things that are
going to happen to you shapes and molds you
to who you are.
Think about the things in life where you are
like “I would never do that again.”
But it still prepares you to be on the lookout
for anything else or to do anything else.
Even if I was to write a book right now, I
think it would be very informative but at
the same time it’s everybody else’s journey.
There is nothing in particular I can give
from that except get as much knowledge as
you can.